TODD: Oh, hi there.
Glad you could join me.
You caught me moonlighting
at my other gig
as an indie game developer.
I am putting a few touches on
the next update of my game,
and my friend Gus
is here to give me
some feedback for
our beta testers.
So, Gus, what's the good news?
GUS: Hey, Todd, so
this new Uber Leet!
achievement that we
added, it's way too easy.
TODD: Really?
GUS: Yeah, I was able to
get it in like five minutes.
TODD: Oh, well, let
me fix that here.
A little coding, and done.
All right, can you
try earning it again?
GUS: Well, I already
have the achievement,
so I can't earn it again.
Can you, like, reset it for me?
TODD: What?
Reset an achievement?
What am I, some sort of wizard?
What's next on your list?
GUS: Well, you know this
new high score leaderboard?
TODD: Yeah.
GUS: Your beta
testers are saying
that there's a bug report
saying that the scores are now
double what they should be.
TODD: Oh, well, I can fix that.
Let's remove the
times two, and done.
All right, ask
them to try again.
GUS: Well, they already
have these super-high scores
on the leaderboard, so
it's going to stay broken.
Can you remove their scores?
TODD: What?
Reset a leaderboard?
Again, not a wizard.
Is there anything else?
GUS: Yeah, a couple of
cheaters found an exploit
to cheat their way to the top
of the fastest time leaderboard.
Can we remove them?
TODD: What?
Remove players
from a leaderboard?
OK, seriously, I
am not a wizard.
Speaking of, what
happened to our wizard?
Didn't we used to
have one on staff?
GUS: Yeah, he left a palantir.
TODD: Wizard!
Well, for those of you who
don't have a wizard on staff,
we have the next best
thing available--
the management APIs for
Google Play game services.
So the management APIs
are a set of rest calls
that do things that an
ordinary player can't do.
Now if you were to
take a look at them,
I'd say 90% fall under the "help
you reset stuff during testing"
category.
So if you want to earn an
achievement for a tester
or clear it so that they can
earn it again, you can do that.
If you want to remove all
scores from the leaderboard
your testing, you
can do that, too.
If you've upgraded, say,
your turn-based data
format and need to kind of
clear out all those old games,
well you can do that as well.
The one exception to all
this is this last 10% here.
And maybe it's the
most important 10%,
because it takes care of
a very important task,
dealing with cheaters.
Yes, in spite of
your best efforts,
cheaters will find their way to
the tops of your leaderboards.
I mean, look at this guy
with his smarmy face.
Don't you just hate him?
I know I do.
But with a couple
of API calls, you
can make sure you never have
to see his cheating face ever
again.
The management APIs
have a hide call,
that basically will block any
scores from this user from any
of your public leaderboards.
Note that this is a
lot more effective
than just removing
a single score.
If you were moved a score,
this cheating player
could go ahead and add
something back 15 minutes later.
God, it's like he's a
cockroach or something,
just keeps coming back.
But with a hide call, you're
essentially hiding everything
from this player
and all the scores
they submit in the future,
which is pretty nice.
Now in the wrong hands,
these management APIs
can be dangerous,
or at the very least
a player could
erase a whole bunch
of scores they didn't mean to.
So you'll notice we have a few
restrictions on these APIs.
First, only the people
in your testers list
can call these APIs.
Now you might think that's
a small number of people,
but remember that if you
have alpha or beta testers,
and you've given them testing
access to game services
here, this might be
a lot more testers
then you originally thought.
Second, management APIs can
only be used on tester accounts
or on game service
resources that
are still in an
unpublished state.
So if you want to erase
an entire leaderboard,
go ahead and do that, as long
as it is a draft leaderboard.
If you want to remove all
achievements from a player,
you can do that, but
only for a test player.
If you want to remove
published achievements
for a normal
player, well, sorry.
That you cannot do.
But remember, if you've got
alpha or beta group selected
as testers here, you
may have the power
to affect more people
than you realize.
And again, the exception to all
of this is those cheater APIs.
These will work on
non-tester accounts,
because cheaters are basically
their own category of person--
really person is
too generous, more
like kind of a bipedal
creature capable
of basic human-like
thought or something.
Anyway, third, we don't have a
lot of client library support.
Now on the one hand,
it seems like there
might be times you
want a convenient,
erase all my achievements
option directly in your game.
But all we need is one or two
beta testers to accidentally
find this button, and you've
got some really angry players
on your hands.
So how do you do this stuff
without a client library?
Well, generally
speaking, you're going
to make raw rest calls
directly, probably from a web
app that you've built yourself
that only a few people
on your test team know
about and have access to.
But wait, you say.
I'm a mobile game developer.
I'm all about, like,
path-finding algorithms
and collision detection
and vertex calling.
I don't have time to
learn about server issues
like making rest calls.
Well, don't worry, my pretty
little polygon pusher.
We have a ready-made web app
that you can download and use.
And with a couple of
configuration steps,
you can set it up to
reset achievements.
You can reset quest progress.
You could delete
a turn-based game,
or you could clear
out a test leaderboard
and hide some cheaters.
Now there's a lot more that
these management APIs can do,
and we'll be adding more
capabilities in the future.
I encourage you to check
out the full documentation,
which we will link to at
the end of this video.
Oh, hey, that reminds me.
I should probably go back to the
studio and check in on things.
All right, Gus.
I have reset your achievement
so you can earn it again.
I have cleared out
that buggy leaderboard,
and I have removed
those cheaters
so we never have to see their
cheating faces ever again.
How's feedback now?
GUS: Yeah, it's still
pretty terrible.
People aren't
digging the update.
TODD: Really?
Is it the new boss fight?
Is it too hard?
GUS: No.
TODD: Is it the epic loot?
Is it not epic enough?
GUS: Nope.
TODD: Is it-- it's not
the new bonus level
where you have to
punch a koala, is it?
GUS: Yeah.
TODD: Philistines.
They just don't understand art.
Do they even get
that the koala was
a metaphor for
oppressive censorship?
GUS: You should have picked a
metaphor that is less fuzzy.
[THEME MUSIC PLAYING]